meet susan an aspiring painter
she wishes to conduct an online painting
exhibition for all her digital artworks
however as the exhibition is online she
is worried that her paintings won't be
secure as anyone could easily forge or
replicate them
her friend mark came to her rescue with
an idea of nfp
he suggested that susan could buy nfts
for all her paintings as nfts are
trustworthy easily transferable and will
also maintain her ownership rights on
her artworks
susan had no idea what nfts were so mark
stepped ahead and explained it to her
nfts turn your digital assets into one
of a kind by creating a unique digital
signature which defines the ownership of
your assets and that can be bought and
sold for real money cryptocurrency or
any other asset like a non-fungible
token aka nft
non-fungible tokens means that they are
not interchangeable and each of them
represents unique assets owned by a
specific person
on the other hand fungible tokens are
interchangeable and can be divided into
smaller units to form the same value
for example a one hundred dollar bill is
fungible as you can exchange it with
five twenty dollar bills or two fifty
dollar bills
but the painting of the last supper is
non-fungible as it cannot be generated
in bulk even if it is copied it will not
be authentic
each nft contains distinguishable
information like who owns the digital
asset and who sold it
making them distinct and easily
verifiable
as it is impossible to forge such a
certificate it will secure her
painting's originality
after learning what nft is susan was
curious to know how exactly nft works
nft basically creates a blockchain based
digital certificate for your digital
collectibles including games music art
and many more
this certificate gives your artwork a
unique identity the underlying
technology and the programming language
used by nfts are the same as other
cryptocurrencies such as blockchain and
the programming language ethash or
script
nft majorly exists on ethereum
blockchain a distributed public ledger
that records all the transactions
however nft is quite different from
these cryptocurrencies bitcoin and
ethereum are fungible tokens which means
if you trade bitcoin or ethereum for one
another you will have the same value or
item in return basically money
on the other hand nft is a unique token
therefore if you try to trade it you may
end up with something completely
different in your hands
crypto punks is a remarkable example of
nft it enables you to buy sell and store
10 000 collectibles with the proof of
ownership being stored on the ethereum
blockchain after exploring helen ft's
work susan was convinced and bought nfts
for all her paintings due to this her
artworks were secured from any kind of
forgery and also gave her artworks a
particular value this contributed to
increased sales too as everyone was
easily able to buy the artwork without
any fear
all in all her exhibition was a complete
success
similarly nft has proved itself to be a
boon in the lives of many others like
jack dorsey the ceo and co-founder of
twitter with his very first and famous
tweet just setting up my twitter and
vignesh sanderson famously known as
medekovan who bought 69.3 million
dollars worth of nft art on people owing
to its increasing popularity people are
now willing to pay hundreds of thousands
of dollars for nfts
nft has enhanced media exposure and
special perks for aspiring artists like
susan on social media
this popularity of nft creates new
opportunities for new art platforms
motivating people to buy art from
internet platforms and promoting
copyright or originality of digital
assets
so here's a question for you what makes
any item non-fungible
a exchangeability b unique digital
signature
c tradeability
d distributed public ledger please give
it a thought and drop your answers in
the comments section below three lucky
winners will receive amazon gift
vouchers
many experts in the crypto industry say
that around forty percent of new crypto
users will use nfts as their entry point
as a result of its growing popularity
nft could represent a more significant
part of the digital economy in the
future
nft and cryptocurrency appears to be the
order of the day these days especially
since the covert 19 pandemic nearly
drove the entire world to code digital
both appear to be a profitable markets
you have probably read stories about
people making hundreds of millions of
dollars using nfcs or headlines about
cryptocurrency values fluctuating and
even crashing as a result of a single
elon musk tree
if you're not familiar with these terms
it's understandable if you have wondered
if nfds and cryptocurrencies are the
same thing
well they aren't
although there are some parallels
between nfts and cryptocurrencies
they're not the same thing
so hello everyone i'm shami and i
welcome you all to this new video of
simply learn on nfps versus crypto
before diving deep into the difference
between nft and cryptocurrency
let's first define what these two are
nft is an acronym for non-funchable
tokens
when it's uni and
can't be replaced with something else
something is said to be non-fungible
each nfp contains
distinguishable information like who
owns the digital asset and who sold it
making them distinct and easily
verifiable as it is impossible to forge
such a certificate
nfc basically creates a blockchain-based
digital certificate for your digital
collectibles including game music art
and many more this certificate gives
your artwork a unique identity
on the other hand cryptocurrency is
defined as a virtual currency that
utilizes cryptography to secure and
verify transactions as well as regulate
and control the generation of new
currency units
it is decentralized and free from any
third-party interference
which means it is not issued and
controlled by any government or central
authority
unlike other payment systems that banks
or governments are handling
cryptocurrency charges almost no a very
low transaction cost there is no limit
for making transactions in fact you have
20.7 access to your money there is no
extra delay or extra charges or making
international transactions and the best
part is that anybody can use
cryptocurrency without the hassles of
paperwork all you need to do is create
an account or any digital wallet of
cryptocurrency
now that we know the basic concept of
both nft and cryptocurrency and
understood the underlying technology
let's move ahead and look into the
comparison parameters for nft versus
crypto
first is trading the process of the
trading in the crypto market
second is purpose
we will differentiate between them by
the purpose behind their concept
third is
volatility in this we will compare the
performance and a volatile nature in the
crypto market
and the fourth and the last one is uses
and marketplaces
in this we will look into the difference
between their users as well as the
marketplaces they are actively used
trading
nfps are bought and traded online and
are managed in digital ledger therefore
they cannot be traded for one another
for example instead of purchasing a
physical photograph to hang on the wall
the buyer receives an original digital
file and he pays for it by money
whereas cryptocurrencies can be traded
or exchanged for each other with no loss
of their value
the peer-to-peer system which works
using blockchain technology enables
anyone to send and receive payment
through any form of digital money or
cryptocurrency
now coming to purpose
each non-functional token serves as a
form of authenticity certificate
indicating that a digital asset is
distinct and not interchangeable
due to the cryptographic principles that
characterize the blockchain and nft can
never be altered adjusted or stolen
cryptocurrency on the other hand like
traditional currencies such as the us
dollar is a medium of exchange designed
to exchange digital information and
solve the
difficulties of traditional currencies
by allowing for quick secure and
decentralized transactions as well as
the purchase and payment of goods and
services
coming to the next one
volatility
although both nfp and cryptocurrency
have unstable volatility nfps are
thought to be less volatile in
comparison to cryptocurrency
artists and traders alike have been
drawn to nfd because of its creative
artistic side on the other hand it may
better individuals who find the tasks of
designing nfps excessively difficult
complicated or inconvenient
but cryptocurrencies in particular are
regarded as high risk investments as
crypto opponents and regulators have
frequently stated in their condemnation
of cryptocurrencies however
certain cryptocurrencies have been
created with the intention of being more
stable than others
and also high-risk comes with high
rewards
now coming to the users and marketplaces
nft is used for digital content gaming
items investment and collateral domain
names and
etc whereas cryptocurrency is used for
low cost money transfers wealth
management ethical business practices
and etc
currently the largest energy
marketplaces are readable openc and
foundation
on the other hand the largest crypto
marketplaces are binance coinbase kraken
and etoro
well now that we know the difference
between nfp and cryptocurrency
let's discuss what's better between them
now if you're artistically inclined and
want to make money for your digital
artwork
and if these are a viable option the
market's creative artistic component has
enticed both artists and traders to
participate
on the other side although cryptos are
slightly unpredictable some
cryptocurrencies have been created to be
more stable than others these
cryptocurrencies are known as stable
coins
and the key advantage is that they have
lower volatility than other
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin or
ethereum
better and usd coin are two examples of
stable coins their worth is determined
by the us dollar's value
so how do you decide which of the two is
the better option
it is determined by the traders
motivation and readiness to take risk
so
this was all about nfd versus crypto do
let me know your thoughts on these
comparisons in the comments section
you have almost reached the end of this
video if i miss anything important do
let me know in the comment section i
hope you enjoyed this video on nfd
versus crypto and learn something new
from it if you like this video then
please do hit the like button thanks for
watching this video and stay tuned for
more updates and videos from temperature
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here